JUSTIN UBERTI: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming to the
session on WebRTC for
plugin-free realtime
communication.
I'm Justin Uberti, tech lead
for WebRTC at Google.
And with me today is-- hey,
has anyone seen Sam?
SAM DUTTON: Hey.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Sam Dutton,
coming to you live from WebRTC
on Chrome for Android.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM DUTTON: On a beautiful
Nexus 7.
We got this low-res to cope
with the Wi-Fi here.
That seems to be working
pretty well.
JUSTIN UBERTI: That was
quite an entrance.
Why don't you come up here
and introduce yourself?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Hey.
I'm Sam Dutton.
I'm a developer advocate
for Chrome.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So we're here to
talk to you today about the
great things that WebRTC's been
working on and how you
can use them.
So what is WebRTC?
In a nutshell, it's what we call
realtime communication--
RTC--
the ability to communicate
live with somebody or
something as if you were right
there next to them.
And this can mean audio,
video, or even just
peer-to-peer data.
And we think WebRTC
is really cool.
But there's a lot of other
people who are really excited
about WebRTC as well.
And one of the reasons is that
WebRTC fills a critical gap in
the web platform, where
previously, a native
proprietary app like Skype could
do something the web
just couldn't.
But now we've turned that around
and changed that so we
have a web of connected WebRTC
devices that can communicate
in realtime just by loading
a web page.
So here's what we're trying to
do with WebRTC, to build the
key APIs for realtime
communication into the web, to
make an amazing media stack in
Chrome so that developers can
build great experiences, and
to use this network of
connected WebRTC devices
to create a new
communications ecosystem.
And these kind of seem
like lofty goals.
But take this quote from the
current CTO of the FCC who
said he sees traditional
telephony fading away as voice
just becomes another web app.
So we're trying to live
up to that promise.
And right now, you can build a
single app with WebRTC that
connects Chrome, Chrome for
Android, Firefox, and very
soon, Opera.
I'm especially excited to
announce the as of this week,
Firefox 22 is going to beta,
which is the very first
WebRTC-enabled version
of Firefox.
So within a matter of weeks, we
will have over one billion
users using a WebRTC-enabled
browser.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN UBERTI: And I think that
just gives a good idea of
the size of the opportunity
here.
And we respect that number to
grow very significantly as
both Chrome and Firefox get
increased adoption.
For places where we don't have
WebRTC-enabled browsers, we're
providing native, supported,
official tool kits on both
Android, and very soon, iOS,
that can interoperate with
WebRTC in the browser.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN UBERTI: So here are
just a handful of the
companies that see the
opportunity in WebRTC and are
building their business
around it.
So that's the vision
for WebRTC.
Now let's dig into the APIs.
There are remain categories of
API that exist in WebRTC.
First, getting access
to input devices--
accessing the microphone,
accessing the webcam, getting
a stream of media from
either of them.
Secondly, being able to connect
to another WebRTC
endpoint across the internet,
and to send this audio and
video in realtime.
And third, the ability to do
this not just for audio and
video, but for arbitrary
application data.
And we think this one is
especially interesting.
So because there's
three categories,
we have three objects.
Three primary objects in WebRTC
to access this stuff.
The first one, MediaStream, for
getting access to media,
then RTCPeerConnection
and RTCDataChannel.
And we'll get into each one
of these individually.
Sam, why don't you tell
us about MediaStream?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, sure.
So MediaStream represents a
single source of synchronized
audio or video or both.
Each MediaStream contains one
or more MediaStream tracks.
For example, on your laptop,
you've got a webcam and a
microphone providing video and
audio streams, and they're
synchronized.
We get access to these local
devices using the getUserMedia
method of Navigator.
So we just look at the code for
that, just highlight that.
And you can see that
getUserMedia there, it takes
three parameters, three
arguments there.
And the first one, if we look
at the constraints argument
I've got, you can see I'm just
specifying I want video.
That's all I'm saying.
Just give me video
and nothing else.
And then in the success
callback, we're setting the
source of a video using the
stream that's returned by
getUserMedia.
Let's see that in action, really
simple example here.
And you can see when we fire
the getUserMedia method, we
get the allow permissions
bar at the top there.
Now, this means that users have
to explicitly opt in to
allowing access to their
microphone and camera.
And yeah, there we have it.
Using that code,
we've got video
displayed in a video element.
Great.
What really excites me about
these APIs is when they come
up against each other,
like in this example.
What's happening is, that we've
got getUserMedia being
piped into a canvas element,
and then the canvas element
being analyzed, and then
producing ASCII, just like
that, which could make a
good codec, I think.
JUSTIN UBERTI: It would
be a good codec.
You can press it using
just gzip.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, smaller font
sizes, high resolution.
Also, another example of
this from Facekat.
Now what's happening here is
that it's using the head
tracker JavaScript library to
track the position of my head.
And when I move around, you can
see I'm moving through the
game and trying to stay alive,
which is quite difficult.
God, this is painful.
Anyway--
whoa.
OK, I think I've flipped
into hyperspace there.
And an old favorite, you've may
well have seen a webcam
toy which gives us access to the
camera, kind of photobooth
app, uses WebGL to create a
bunch of slightly psychedelic
effects there.
I quite this old movie
one, so I'll take
that and get a snapshot.
And I can share that with my
friends, so beautiful work
from Paul Neave there.
Now you might remember I said
that we can use the
constraints object.
The simple example there was
just saying, use the video,
nothing else.
Well, we can do more interesting
things with
constraints than that.
We can do stuff like specify
the resolution or the frame
rate, a whole stack of
things that we want
from our local devices.
A little example from that,
if we go over here.
Now, let's look at the
code, actually.
If we go to the dev tools there,
you can see that I've
got three different constraints
objects, one for
each resolution.
So when I press the buttons,
I use the QVGA constraints,
getUserMedia, and then with the
VGA one, I'm getting high
resolution.
And for HD, I'm getting
the full 1280 by 720.
We can also use getUserMedia
now for input from our
microphone.
In other words, we can use
getUserMedia to provide a
source node for web audio.
And there's a huge amount of
interesting stuff we can do
with that processing audio using
web audio, from the mic
or wherever.
A little example
of that here--
I'll just allowed access to the
mic, and you can see, I'm
getting a nice little
visualization there in the
canvas element.
And I can start to
record this, blah
blah blah blah blah--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-To record this, blah blah
blah blah blah--
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
SAM DUTTON: And yeah, you can
see that's used recorder.js to
save that locally to disk.
GetUserMedia also now-- this is
kind of experimental, but
we can use getUserMedia to get
a screen capture, in other
words data coming directly from
what we see on screen,
not from the audio video from
the mic and the camera.
Probably the simplest if I show
you an example of this,
so yeah, a little application
here.
And when I click to make the
call, allow, and you can see
there that I get this kind of
crazy hall of mirrors effect,
because I'm capturing the screen
that I'm capturing, and
so on and so on.
Now that's quite nice.
But it would be really useful
if we could take that screen
capture and then transmit that
to another computer.
And for that, we have
RTCPeerConnection.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Thanks, Sam.
So as the name implies,
RTCPeerConnection is all about
making a connection to another
peer and over this peer
connection, we can actually
then go and
send audio and video.
And the way we do this is we
take the media streams that
we've got from getUserMedia, and
we plug them into the peer
connection, and send them
off to the other side.
When the other side receives
them, they'll pop out as a new
media stream on their
peer connection.
And they can then plug that
into a video element to
display on the page.
And so both sides of a peer
connection, they both get
streams from getUserMedia, they
plug them in, and then
those media streams pop out
magically encoded and decoded
on the other side.
Now under the hood,
peer connection is
doing a ton of stuff--
signal processing to remove
noise from audio and video;
codec selection and compression
and decompression
of the actual audio and video;
finding the actual
peer-to-peer route through
firewalls, through NATs,
through relays; encrypting the
data so that a user's data is
fully protected at all times;
and then actually managing the
bandwidth so that if you have
two megabits, we use it.
If you have 200 kilobits,
that's all we use.
But we do everything we can hide
this complexity from that
web developer.
And so the main thing is that
you get your media streams,
you plug them in via
Adstream to peer
connection, and off you go.
And here's a little
example of this.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, so you can see
here that we've created a
new RTCPeerConnection.
And when the stream is received,
the callback for
that in gotRemoteStream there
attaches the media we're
getting from a video element
to the stream.
Now, at the same time, we're
also creating what's called an
offer, giving information about
media, and we're setting
that as the local description,
and then sending that to the
callee, so that they can set
the remote description.
You can see that in the
gotAnswer function there.
Let's have a little look at
RTCPeerConnection on one page,
a very simple example here.
So what we've got here
is getUserMedia here,
just start that up.
So it's getting video from the
local camera here, displaying
it on the left there.
Now when I press call, it's
using RTCPeerConnection to
communicate that video
to the other--
yeah, the other video element
on the page there.
This is a great place to start
to get your head around
RTCPeerConnection.
And if we look in the code
there, you can see that it's
really simple.
There's not a lot of code there
to do that, to transmit
video from one peer
to another.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So that's
really cool stuff.
A full video chat client in a
single web page, and just
about 15 lines of JavaScript.
And we talked a bit quickly
through the whole thing around
how we set up the parameter of
the call, the offers and
answers, but I'll come
back to that later.
The next thing I want to talk
about is RTCDataChannel.
And this says, if we have a peer
connection which already
creates our peer-to-peer link
for us, can we send arbitrary
application data over it?
And this is the mechanism
that we use to do so.
Now one example where we would
do this would be in a game.
Like, take this game.
I think it's called Jank
Wars or something.
And we have all these ships
floating around onscreen.
Now, when a ship moves, we
want to make sure that's
communicated to the other player
as quickly as possible.
And so we have this little JSON
object that contains the
parameters and the position and
the velocity of the ships.
And we can just take that object
and stuff it into the
send method, and it will shoot
it across the other side where
it pops out as onMessage.
And the other side can
do the same thing.
It can call send on its data
channel, and it works pretty
much just like a WebSocket.
That's not an accident.
And we tried to design it that
way, so that people familiar
with using WebSockets could
also use a similar API for
RTCDataChannel.
And the benefit is that here,
we have a peer-to-peer
connection with the lowest
possible latency for doing
this communication.
In addition, RTCDataChannel.
can be either unreliable
or reliable.
And we can think about this kind
of like UDP versus TCP.
If you're doing a game, it's
more important that your
packets get there quickly
than they're
guaranteed to get there.
Whereas if you're doing a file
transfer, the files are only
any good if the entire
file is delivered.
So you can choose this as the
app developer, which mode you
want to use, either unreliable
or reliable.
And lastly, everything
is fully secure.
We use standard DTLS encryption
to make sure that
the packages you send across
the data channel are fully
encrypted on their way
to the destination.
And you can do this either with
audio and video, or if
you want to make a peer
connection for just data, you
can do that as well.
So Sam's going to show us
how this actually works.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, so again,
another really simple example.
We're creating a peer connection
here, and once the
data channel is received, in
the callback to that, we're
setting the receive
channel using the
event.channel object.
Now, when the receive channel
gets a message, kind of like
WebSocket really, we're just
putting some text in a local
div there, using event.data.
Now, the send channel
was created with
createDataChannel.
And then we got a send button.
When that's clicked, we get the
data from a text area, and
we use the send channel to send
that to the other peer.
Again, let's see
this in action.
This is, again, a good place to
start-- one page demo, with
all the code for RTCDataChannel,
so type in
some text, and we hit send, and
it's transmitting it to
the other text area.
A great place to start
if you're looking at
RTCDataChannel.
Something a little more
useful here, a
great app from Sharefest.
Now, Sharefest is using
RTCDataChannel.
to enable us to do
file sharing.
I think I'm going to select a
nice photo here I've got of
some cherries.
And it's popeye, is the URL.
And now Justin is going to try
and get that up on screen on
his side, just to check that
that's gone through.
So like I say, this is doing
file sharing using
RTCDataChannel, and there's
a huge amount
of potential there.
There we go.
Those are the cherries.
JUSTIN UBERTI: I
love cherries.
SAM DUTTON: These are beautiful
Mountain View
cherries, actually.
They were really, really nice.
JUSTIN UBERTI: All this data
is being sent peer-to-peer,
and anybody else who connects to
the same URL will download
that data peer-to-peer
from Sam's machine.
And so none of this has to
touch Sharefest servers.
And I think that's pretty
interesting if you think about
things like file transfer and
bulk video distribution.
OK, so we talked a lot about
how we can do really clever
peer-to-peer stuff with
RTCPeerConnection.
But it turns out we need servers
to kind of get the
process kicked off.
And the first part of it is
actually making sure that both
sides can agree to actually
conduct the session.
And this is the process that
we call signaling.
The signaling in WebRTC is
abstract, which means that
there's no fully-defined
protocol on
exactly how you do it.
The key part is that you just
have to exchange session
description objects.
And if you think about this kind
of like a telephone call,
when you make a call to someone,
the telephone network
sends a message to the person
you're calling, telling them
there's an incoming call and
the phone should ring.
Then, when they answer the call,
they send a message back
that says, the call
is now active.
Now, these messages also contain
parameters around what
media format to use, where the
person is on the network, and
the same is true for WebRTC.
And these things, these session
description objects,
contain parameters like, what
codecs to use, what security
keys to use, the network
information for setting up the
peer-to-peer route.
And the only important thing is
that you just send it from
your side to the other
side, and vice versa.
You can use any mechanism
you want--
WebSockets, Google Cloud
Messaging, XHR.
You can use any protocol, even
just send it as JSON, or you
can use a standard protocols
like SIP or XMPP.
Here's a picture of how
this all works.
The app gets a session
description from the browser
and sends it across through the
cloud to the other side.
Once it gets the message back
from the other side with the
other side's session
description, and both sessions
consider passed down to WebRTC
in the browser, WebRTC can
then set up and conduct the
media link peer-to-peer.
So we do a lot to try to hide
the details of what's inside
the RTCSessionDescription,
because this includes a whole
bunch of parameters--
as I said, codecs, network
information,
all sorts of stuff--
this is just a snippet of what's
contained inside a
session description right now.
Really advanced apps can do
complex behaviors by modifying
this, but we designed API so
that regular apps just don't
have to think about it.
The other thing that we need
servers for is to actually get
the peer-to-peer session
fully routed.
And in the old days, this
wouldn't be a problem.
A long time ago, each side
had a public IP address.
They send each other's IP
address to each other through
the cloud, and we make the link
directly between the peers.
Well, in the age of NAT, things
are more complicated.
NATs hand out what's called a
private IP address, and these
IP addresses are not useful
for communication.
There's no way we can make the
link actually peer-to-peer
unless we have public address.
So this is where we bring a
technology called STUN.
The STUN server we can contact
from WebRTC, and we say,
what's my public IP address?
And basically, the request comes
into the STUN server, it
sees the address that that
request came from, puts the
address into the packet,
and sends it back.
So now WebRTC knows its public
IP address, and the STUN
server doesn't have to be in
the party anymore, doesn't
have to have media flowing
through it.
So here, if you look at this
example, each side has
contacted that STUN server to
find out what its public IP
address is.
And then it's sent the traffic
to the other IP address
through its NAT, and the data
still flows peer-to-peer.
So this is kind of magic stuff,
and it usually works.
Usually we can make sure that
the data all flows properly
peer-to-peer, but not
in every case.
And for that, we have a
technology called TURN built
into WebRTC.
This turn things around and
provides a cloud fallback when
a peer-to-peer link is
impossible, basically asks for
a relay in the cloud, saying,
give me a public address.
And because this public address
is in the cloud,
anybody can contact it, which
means the call always sets up,
even if you're behind
a restrictive, or
even behind a proxy.
The downside is that since the
data actually is being relayed
through the server, there is
an operational cost to it.
But it does mean the call
works in almost all
environments.
Now, on one hand, we have STUN,
which is super cheap,
but doesn't always work.
And we have TURN, which
always works, but has
some cost to it.
How do we make sure we get
the best of both worlds?
Here's TURN in action, where
we try to use STUN and STUN
didn't work.
And we couldn't get the
things to actually
penetrate the NATs.
So instead, we fell back.
Only then did we use TURN, and
sent the media from our one
peer, through the NAT, through
the TURN server, and to the
other side.
And this is all done by a
technology called ICE.
ICE knows about STUN and TURN,
and tries all the things in
parallel to figure out the
best path for the call.
If it can do STUN,
it does STUN.
If it can do TURN, well then
I'll fall back to TURN, but
I'll do so quickly.
And we have stats from a
deployed WebRTC application
that says 86% of the time,
we can make things
work with just STUN.
So only one out of seven calls
actually have to run through a
TURN server.
So how do you deploy TURN
for your application?
Well, we have some testing
servers, a testing STUN server
that you can use, plus we make
source code available for our
own STUN and TURN server
as part of
the WebRTC code package.
But the thing I would really
recommend is the long name,
but really good product--
rfc5766-turn-server--
which has Amazon VM images
that you can just take,
download, and deploy into the
cloud, and you've got your
TURN server provisioned for all
your users right there.
I also recommend restund,
another TURN server that we've
used with excellent results.
One question that comes up
around WebRTC is, how is
security handled?
And the great thing is that
security has been built into
WebRTC from the very beginning,
and so this means
several different things.
It means we have mandatory
encryption for
both media and data.
So all the data that's being
sent by WebRTC is being
encrypted using standard
AES encryption.
We also have secure UI, meaning
the user's camera
microphone can only be accessed
if they've explicitly
opted in to making that
functionality available.
And last, WebRTC runs inside
the Chrome sandbox.
So even if somebody tries to
attack WebRTC inside of
Chrome, the browser and the user
will be fully protected.
So here's what you need to do
to take advantage of the
security in WebRTC,
is really simple.
Your app just needs
to use HTTPS for
actually doing the signaling.
As long as the signaling goes
over a secure conduit, the
data will be fully secured as
well using the standard
protocols of SRTP for media
or Datagram TLS
for the data channel.
One more question that comes
up is around making a
multi-party call, a
conference call.
How should I architect
my application?
In the simple two-party
case, it's easy.
We just have a peer-to-peer
link.
But as you start adding more
peers into the mix, things get
a bit more complicated.
And one approach that people use
is a mesh, where basically
every peer connects to
every other peer.
And this is really simple,
because there's no servers or
anything involved, other than
the signaling stuff.
But every peer has to send
and copy this data
to every other peer.
So this has a corresponding
CPU and bandwidth cost.
So depending on the media
you're trying to send--
for audio, it can be
kind of higher.
For video, it's going to be
less-- the number of peers you
can support in this topology is
fairly limited, especially
if one of the peers is
on a mobile device.
To deal with that another
architecture that can be used
is the star architecture.
And here, you can pick the most
capable device to be what
we call the focus
for the call.
And the focus is the part that's
actually responsible
for taking the data and sending
a copy to each of the
other endpoints.
But as we get to handing
multiple HD video streams, the
job for a focus becomes
pretty difficult.
And so for the most robust
conferencing architecture, we
recommend an MCU, or multipoint
control unit.
And this is a server that's
custom made for relaying large
amounts of audio and video.
And it can do various things.
It can do selective
stream forwarding.
It can actually mix the
audio or video data.
It can also do things
like recording.
And so if one peer drops out, it
doesn't interrupt the whole
conference, because the MCU is
taking care of everything.
So WebRTC is made with
standards in mind.
And so you can connect
things that
aren't even WebRTC devices.
And one thing that people want
to talk from WebRTC is phones.
And there's a bunch of easy
things they can be dropped
into your web page to
make this happen.
There's a sipML5, which is
a way to talk to various
standard SIP devices, Phono, and
what we're going to show
you now, a widget from Zingaya
to make a phone call.
SAM DUTTON: OK, so we've got a
special guest joining us a
little bit later in
the presentation.
I just wanted to give him a call
to see if he's available.
So let's use the Zingaya
WebRTC phone app now.
And you could see, it's
accessing my microphone.
[PHONE DIALING AND RINGING]
SAM DUTTON: Calling someone.
I hope it's the person I want.
[PHONE RINGING]
SAM DUTTON: See if he's there.
CHRIS WILSON: Hello?
SAM DUTTON: Hey.
Is that you, Chris?
CHRIS WILSON: Hey, Sam.
How's it going?
It is.
SAM DUTTON: Hey.
Fantastic.
I just want to check you're
ready for your gig later on.
CHRIS WILSON: I'm ready
whenever you are.
SAM DUTTON: That's fantastic.
OK, speak to you soon, Chris.
Thanks.
Bye bye.
CHRIS WILSON: Talk
to you soon.
Bye.
SAM DUTTON: Cheers.
JUSTIN UBERTI: It's great--
no plugins, realtime
communication.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, that
situation, we had
a guy with a telephone.
Something we were thinking
about is situations where
there is no telephone network.
Now, Voxio demonstrated this
with something called Tethr,
which is kind of disaster
communications in a box.
It uses the open BTS cell
framework-- you can see, it's
that little box there-- to
enable calls between feature
phones via the open BTS cell
through WebRTC to computers.
You can imagine this is kind
of fun to get a license for
this in downtown San Francisco,
but this is
incredibly useful in situations
where there is no
infrastructure.
Yeah, this is like telephony
without a
carrier, which is amazing.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So we have a code
lab this afternoon that I
hope you can come to, where
I'll really go into the
details of exactly how to build
a WebRTC application.
But now we're going to talk
about some resources that I
think are really useful.
The first one is something
called WebRTC Internals.
And this is a page you can open
up just by going to this
URL while you're in
a WebRTC call.
And it'll show all sorts of
great statistics about what's
actually happening
inside your call.
This would be things like packet
loss, bandwidth, video
resolution and sizes.
And there's also a full log of
all the calls made to the
WebRTC API that you can
download and export.
So if a customer's reporting
problems with their call, you
can easily get this debugging
information from them.
Another thing is, the
WebRTC spec has been
updating fairly rapidly.
And so in a given browser, the
API might not always match the
latest spec.
Well, adapter.js is something
that's there to insulate the
web developer from the
differences between browsers
and the differences
between versions.
And so we make sure that
adapter.js always implements
the latest spec, and then thunks
down to whatever the
version supports.
So as new APIs are added, we
polyfill them to make sure
that you don't have to write
custom version code or custom
browser code for each browser.
And we use this in our
own applications.
SAM DUTTON: OK, if all this is
too much for you, good news
is, we've got some fantastic
JavaScript frameworks come up
in the last few months, really
great abstraction libraries to
make it really, really simple to
build WebRTC apps just with
a few lines of code.
Example here from SimpleWebRTC,
a little bit of
JavaScript there to specify a
video element that represents
local video, and one that
represents the remote video
stream coming in.
And then join a room just by
calling the joinRoom method
with a room name--
really, really simple.
PeerJS does something similar
for RTCDataChannel--
create a peer, and then on
connection, you can send
messages, receive messages, so
really, really easy to use.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So JavaScript
frameworks go a long way, but
they don't cover the production
aspects of the service--
the signaling, the STUN and TURN
service we talked about.
But fortunately, we have things
from both OpenTok and
Vline that are basically turnkey
WebRTC services that
handle all this stuff for you.
You basically sign up for the
service, get an API key, and
then you can make calls
using their production
infrastructure, which is spread
throughout the entire globe.
They also make UI widgets that
can be easily dropped into
your WebRTC app.
So you get up and running
with WebRTC super fast.
Now, we've got a special
treat for you today.
Chris Wilson, a colleague of
ours, and a developer in the
original Mosaic browser, and
an occasional musician as
well, is going to be joining us
courtesy of WebRTC to show
off the HD video quality and
full-band audio quality that
we're now able to offer in the
latest version of Chrome.
Take it away, Chris.
CHRIS WILSON: Hey, guys.
SAM DUTTON: Hey, Chris.
How's it going?
CHRIS WILSON: I'm good.
How are you?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, good.
Have you got some kind of
musical instrument with you?
CHRIS WILSON: I do.
You know, originally
you asked me for a
face-melting guitar solo.
But I'm a little more
relaxed now.
I/O is starting to wind down.
You can tell I've already got
my Hawaiian shirt on.
I'm not ready for
some vacation.
So I figured I'd bring my
ukulele and hook it up through
a nice microphone here, so we
can listen to how that sounds.
SAM DUTTON: Take it away.
Melt my face, Chris.
[PLAYING UKULELE]
SAM DUTTON: That's
pretty good.
JUSTIN UBERTI: He's
All right.
SAM DUTTON: That
was beautiful.
Thank you, Chris.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS WILSON: All right, guys.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Chris
Wilson, everybody.
SAM DUTTON: The audience
has gone crazy, Chris.
Thank you very much.
JUSTIN UBERTI: You want
to finish up?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
So, we've had-- well, a fraction
over 30 minutes to
cover a really big topic.
There's a great lot of more
information out there online,
some good stuff on HTML5 Rocks,
and a really good
e-book too, if you want to
take a look at that.
There are several ways
to contact us.
There's a great Google group--
discuss-webrtc--
post your technical questions.
All the kind of new news for
WebRTC comes through on
Google+ and Twitter stream.
And we're really grateful of
all the people, all of you
who've submitted feature
requests and bugs.
And please keep them coming,
and the URL for that is
crbug.com/new.
So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN UBERTI: And so we've
built this stuff into the web
platform to make realtime
communication
accessible to everyone.
And we're super excited because
we can't wait to see
what you all are
going to build.
So thank you for coming.
Once again, the link.
And now, if you have any
questions, we'll be happy to
try to answer them.
Thank you very much.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Mark.
I like to know, because I'm
using Linux and Ubuntu, how
finally can I get rid of the
talk plugin for using Hangouts
in Google+?
JUSTIN UBERTI: The question
is, when can we get rid of
that Hangouts plug-in?
And so unfortunately, we
can only talk about
WebRTC matters today.
That's handled by
another team.
But let's say that there
are many of us who
have the same feeling.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you make any
comments on Microsoft's
competing standard, considering
they kind of hold
the cards with Skype, and how
maybe we can go forward
supporting both or maybe
converge the two, or just your
thoughts on that?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So Microsoft
has actually been a great
participant in standards.
They have several people they
sent from their team.
And although they don't see
things exactly the same way
that we do, I think that the API
differences are sort of,
theirs is a lot more low-level,
geared for expert
developers.
Ours is a little more
high-level, geared for web
developers.
And I think that really what
you can do is you can
implement the high-level one on
top of the low-level one,
maybe even vice versa.
So Microsoft is a little more
secretive about what they do.
So we don't know exactly
what their timeframe
is relative to IE.
But they're fully
participating.
And obviously, they're very
interested in Skype.
So I'm very optimistic that
we'll see a version of IE that
supports this technology in the
not-too-distant future.
AUDIENCE: Very good to hear.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question would be,
I think you mentioned it
quickly in the beginning.
So if I wanted to communicate
with WebRTC, but one, I'm
using a different environment
than the browser.
Let's say I want a web
application to speak to a
native Android app.
So what would be the approach to
integrate that with WebRTC?
JUSTIN UBERTI: As I mentioned
earlier, we have a fully
supported official native
version of pure connection,
PureConnection.Java, which is
open source, and you can
download, and you can build
that into your native
application.
And it interoperates.
We have a demo app that
interoperates with
our AppRTC demo app.
So I think that using Chrome for
Android in a web view is
one thing you can think about.
But if that doesn't work for
you, we have a native version
that works great.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question would be, are there
any things that to be
taken care between cross-browser
compatibility
for this Firefox Chrome?
Anything specific that
needs to be taken
care, or it just works?
JUSTIN UBERTI: There are
some minor differences.
I mentioned adapter.js covers
some of the things where the
API isn't quite in sync
in both places.
One specific thing is that
Firefox only supports the opus
codec, and they only support
DTLS encryption.
They don't support something
called S-DES,
that we also support.
So for right now, you have to
set one parameter in the API,
and you can see that in our app
RTC source code, to make
sure that communication
actually uses
those compatible protocols.
We actually have a document,
though, on our web page, the
documents exactly what you have
to do, which is really
setting a single constraint
parameter when you're creating
your peer connection object.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
If you go to webrtc.org/interop.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
That works at org/interop.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When a peer connection
is made and it
falls back to TURN, does the
TURN server, is it capable of
unencrypting the messages that
go between the two endpoints?
JUSTIN UBERTI: No.
The TURN server is just
a packet relay.
So this stuff is fully
encrypted.
It doesn't have the keying
information to
do anything to it.
So the TURN server just takes a
byte, sends a byte, takes a
packet, sends a packet.
AUDIENCE: So for keeping data
in sync with low latency
between, say, an Android
application and the server,
how would both the native
and the Android Chrome
implementations of WebRTC fare
in terms of battery life?
JUSTIN UBERTI: I don't really
have a good answer for that.
I wouldn't think there would
be much difference.
I mean, the key things that
are going to be driving
battery consumption
in this case--
are you talking about data,
or are you talking
about audio and video?
AUDIENCE: Data.
JUSTIN UBERTI: For data, the
key drivers of your power
consumption are going to be the
screen and the network.
And so I think those should be
comparable between Chrome for
Android and the native
application.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: With two computers
running Chrome, or what have
you seen glass-to-glass
latency?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Repeat?
AUDIENCE: Glass-to-glass, so
from the camera to the LCD.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Oh, yeah.
So it depends on a platform,
because the camera can have a
large delay built
into it itself.
Also, some of the audio
things have higher
latencies than others.
But the overall target is 150
milliseconds end-to-end.
And we've seen lower than 100
milliseconds in best case
solutions for glass-to-glass
type latency.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And how are you ensuring
priority of your data across
the network?
JUSTIN UBERTI: That's a complex
question with a long answer.
But the basic thing, are you
saying, how do we compete with
cat videos?
AUDIENCE: No, just within the
WebRTC, are you just--
how are you tagging
your packets?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right, so there
is something called DSCP where
we can mark QoS bits-- and this
isn't yet implemented in
WebRTC, but it's on the roadmap,
to be able to tag
things like audio as higher
priority than, say, video, and
that as a higher priority
than cat videos.
AUDIENCE: So it's not today,
but will be done?
JUSTIN UBERTI: It
will be done.
We also have things for doing
FEC type mechanisms to protect
things at the application
layer.
But the expectation is that as
WebRTC becomes more pervasive,
carriers will support DSCP at
least on the bit from coming
off the computer and going
onto their network.
And we have that DSCP does
help going through Wi-Fi
access points, because Wi-Fi
access points to give priority
to DSCP-marked traffic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So in Chrome for iOS
being limited to UI web view
and with other restrictions, how
much of WebRTC will you be
able to implement?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So that's a
really interesting question.
They haven't made it easy for
us, but the Chrome for iOS
team has already done some
amazing things to deliver the
Chrome experience that
exists there now.
And so we're pretty optimistic
that one way or another, we
can find some way to
make that work.
No commitment to the
time frame, though.
AUDIENCE: What are the
mechanisms for a saving video
and audio that's broadcast with
WebRTC, like making video
recordings from it?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So if you have
the media stream, you can then
take the media stream and plug
it into things like the Web
Rdio API, where you can actually
get the raw samples,
and then make a wave file
and save that out.
On the video side, you can go
into a canvas, and then
extract the frames from a
canvas, and you can save that.
There isn't really any way to
sort of save it as a .MP4,
.WEBM file yet.
But if you want to make a thing
that just captures audio
from the computer then it stores
on a server, you could
basically make a custom server
that could do that recording.
That's one option.
AUDIENCE: So the TURN
server is open--
but you said the TURN server
doesn't capture.
JUSTIN UBERTI: No.
AUDIENCE: It can't act
as an endpoint.
Do you have server technology
that acts as an endpoint?
JUSTIN UBERTI: There
are people building
this sort of stuff.
Vline might be one particular
vendor who does this, but
there's something where you can
basically have an MCU, and
the MCU that receives the media
could then do things
like compositing or recording
of that media.
AUDIENCE: So presumably, the
libraries for Java or
Objective C could be used
to create a server
implementation?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Exactly.
That's what they're doing.
AUDIENCE: Hi, kind of two-part
question that has to do around
codecs, specifically
on the video side,
currently VP8, WebM.
Is there plans for H.264,
and also what's the
timeline for VP9?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Our plans are
around the VP family of
codecs, so we support VP8.
And VP9, you may have heard that
it's sort of trying to
finalize the bit stream
right now.
So we are very much looking
forward to taking advantage of
VP9 with all its new coding
techniques, once it's both
finished and also optimized
for realtime.
AUDIENCE: And H.264, not
really on the plan?
JUSTIN UBERTI: We think that
VP9 provides much better
compression and overall
performance than H.264, so we
have no plans as far as
H.264 at this time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Running WebRTC on
Chrome or Android for mobile
and tablets, how does it
compare with native
performance, like Hangouts
on Android?
JUSTIN UBERTI: We think that
we provide a comparable
performance to any native
application right now.
We're always trying to
make things better.
We still have Chrome for
Android, the WebRTC's behind a
flag because we still have work
to do around improving
audio, improvement some
of the performance.
But we think we can deliver
equivalent performance on the
web browser.
And we're also working on taking
advantage of hardware
acceleration, in cases where
there's hardware decoders like
there is on Nexus 10, and making
that so we can get the
same sort of down-to-the-metal
performance that you could get
from a native app.
AUDIENCE: So the Google Talk
plugin is using not just
H.264, but H.264 SVC optimized
for the needs of
videoconferencing.
Is VP8 and VP9 going to
be similarly optimized
specifically in an SVC-like
fashion for video conferencing
versus just the versions
for file encoding?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So VP8 already
supports temporal scalability
in the S part of SVC.
VP9 supports additional
scalability modes as well.
So we're very excited about the
new coding techniques that
are coming in VP9.
AUDIENCE: So we want to use
WebRTC to do live streaming
from, let's say, cameras,
hardware cameras.
And what are the things that
we should take care of such
kind of an application?
And when you mentioned
VP8 and VP9 support,
H.264 is not supported.
Assuming your hardware supports
only H.264, WebRTC
can be used with Chrome
in that case?
JUSTIN UBERTI: We are building
up support for hardware VP8,
and later, VP9 encoders.
So you can make a media
streaming application like you
described, but we're expecting
that all the major SSE vendors
are now shipping hardware
with built-in VP8
encoders and decoders.
So as this stuff gets into
market, you're going to see
this stuff become the most
efficient way to record and
compress data.
AUDIENCE: So the only way is
to support VP8 in hardware
right now, right?
JUSTIN UBERTI: If you want
hardware compression, the only
things that we support right
now will be VP8 encoders.
AUDIENCE: That's on the device
side, you know, the camera
which is on--
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right.
If you're having encoding from
a device that you want to be
decoded within the browser, I
advise you to do it in VP8.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Thank
you all for coming.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]